last week I was asked to give a talk and
so I said yeah I want to talk about
kubernetes cuz that's something I'm
excited about these days and then I was
like oh wait I'm gonna conference with
data scientists I don't know how many of
them actually run their own cluster or
run their aren't their own layers of
things and so then I said well I'll try
to kind of bring it down a bit and like
talk about what kubernetes like what it
is why and everything else and even then
I got sitting down and thinking about
and like I end up writing a whole talk
on why I need kubernetes so how many
people came to the talk to learn about
like how kubernetes works awesome I you
you folks are the only people I'm gonna
disappoint there's only five of you in
the room that's awesome
how many people know what kubernetes is
already okay maybe five more folks how
many people run clusters or run their
own hardware or run like actually run a
production system in some some capacity
awesome ok so this talk actually is
going to hit on point so I'm not going
to go into as much detail about all the
systems from the top to bottom but I'm
going to go into details about when what
the systems people think about and more
especially like so I joined passion
metric about a year or almost two years
ago and like about a year ago I got to
this point I have delivered a working
model life was great and you know like
all of a sudden you know we're startup
you know millions of dollars are
flashing through our eyes or like we're
gonna solve the world's problems we've
we have a model and and I actually put
up your model complete which is I was
trying to be funny you know it's gonna
have like George Bush on a carrier or
something like because it's like mission
complete like it's a model ever complete
I mean no I mean everyone knows that
there's no such thing as a complete
model but you do deliver something and
at that point you're like ha my job is
done and so I think that a lot of people
here at this conference
are talking about getting to this point
where you can deliver some actionable
intelligence on that model then there's
like what is the next step from there
and I think it does do a lot if you
understand what's gonna happen in order
to make that money off of that model so
I'm going to go through a little bit
about how you're gonna make money with
that model what you need to do to bit
look what needs to happen to be built
around that system to deliver the the
analytics from that model and then I'm
going to talk about how docker and
kubernetes and anaconda can solve all
your problems you don't have to ever
evaluate another tool again of course
but first what does my model do so my
model does this I take in data about
people and I produce on the order of 50
different body measurements that tailors
can use or clothing users can use and
then we predict clothing so we come like
my founders come from a long line of
tailors and there's a lot of standards
around measuring bodies and
understanding bodies and we've taken
that and built a pretty robust data
science process and so now as raw form
like things about your body isn't
exactly just useful but there are lots
of folks who can for example there's
definitely people who will make suits
out of yours and out of some of these
measurements and every one of them has a
different set of measurements and
there's a different set of like each
piece of clothing for example guys don't
know this as well as females but you
know there is a vanity sizing right so
whatever actually fits on your body is
completely arbitrary and so yeah there's
some nods I mean you know actually I use
a so I I'm a big man so yeah that portly
is what I think the industry's term is
and so like I go to Hugo Boss I wear
like a neck cell I go to hammer crappie
I wear like triple XL and they slightly
show me the door because they can't fit
me right or the English clothing is
another one I try to try to use my
algorithms their english clothing and
england doesn't make clothing for me
that's what i've determined
so there's definitely like trends and
things in the industry and we help
people understand those through body
language so we can't just give them you
know the the body data we have to help
serve them a solution or something that
help them get through this process you
have data I have customers how am I
going to fit them so while I have a
model I have to create a solution that
helps their customers so my customers
are big enterprise companies that sell
clothing online or small businesses
sometimes but what there's a lot of data
science behind the tool but this is the
thing that you know the sales people are
going to see this is a thing that's like
this has to be responsive and all of a
sudden like the data science goes out
the window and you're like oh so
frustrated so I think it's good to
understand a little bit about that
process like what is like at the end of
the day you have to kind of deliver this
and how do people actually do that okay
so that's what I do so now I'm going to
go through a little bit about the
business case so I'm just kind of
established we're we're Enterprise SAS
company we have a data API that we have
solutions on top of like that little
form that then will return clothing for
you and then there's more services on
top of that because you can't just give
someone a solution you have to at least
charge them six hundred dollars an hour
doesn't make that solution work I mean
that's the business come on no laughs
okay so here's the model
people always say what's your business
model the enterprise SAS has a very
simple business model revenue goes up
costs go down okay so this seems really
stupid that why would you even put this
on here but the unit of the unit of
price is typically something to do with
those API calls
so and this is this actually this chart
comes from Thomas tongues who was early
p.m. at Salesforce and like knows a lot
about trying to make these things work
but the other day you want your revenue
to be an exponential curve but your cost
typical is something like a linear curve
going down but the other interesting
thing is why so many VCS interested
because it's definitely one of these
places where there's you can spend a lot
more on costs at the beginning but as
you scaled needs to like rapidly drive
off and why bring this up is because you
have to take this into account so you're
gonna have more money at the beginning
of your project to build out something
then you and it has to scale and be
repeatable so anything you do has to
repeat very quickly and in our case of
our business I mean when we started a
year ago yet we went from like 500 to
20,000 calls a day so very much the case
where you really I do start growing a
lot of calls a lot very quickly like
that's a whole web scale thing right so
that's kind of the model how do I make
sure that my cost keep on going down as
I get this exponential growth of expense
to deliver or things deliver so let's
build an API like we do it through an
API the delivery mechanism is a restful
api that can be called by anybody you
can you can cache it you can do a lot of
piece of things to make that faster but
what are the parts of like the business
model around the the api and the big
part and this seems like really high
level and kind of silly but it drives
like the technical decisions later on so
bear with me a little bit so you break
down your API as like a legal agreement
which is your SLA which everybody
everyone kind of everywhere sort of an
SLA right so if you try to give your
tech if you tech people trying to just
do an SLA that's not really what's going
on I'll tell you a little bit about why
it's a broken model so but that's a
legal agreement but they need objectives
like how many times is this thing going
to be called what's your server loads
going
be and how would your response times and
so you have to build metrics out of that
though in order to say that you actually
agreed you're meeting your agreement and
then you also have to build data and
less service level indicators or data
around your entire system to say what
your metrics are I think a big one for
me
is like how many how many times are
people actually in my data are out of my
data outliers became a big deal for us
because turns out a lot of people don't
inter forms correctly and I have lots of
people who will say they're you know
four foot tall and 300 pounds and I'm
sure those people exist but I have to
like kind of say yeah that's great but
maybe you should go into a store or
something because my model is not going
to be performing here and things like
that and so but the but that becomes an
indicator that kind of comes back up to
the level agreements who the big thing
here is like you have to build a
monitoring system you can't just build
the system you have to build a system
that can be have indicators that can be
objectives which another kind of lot of
data scientists work on that piece the
thing goes up to a legal team there's
typically in any one of these contracts
there's about there's usually I guess
there's a standard contract kind of goes
out it's like three parts typically has
an uptime as a response time and as like
over support a support request time or a
support response time I'm not gonna go
into like all like details about every
single item there but these are like
what you have to do if I'm gonna deliver
you data science I have to tell you how
how often I can give it to you how fast
it can give to it and and if it messes
up how quickly I can fix it
so an API uptime is is anybody not know
what like nines are like if I say three
nines okay so I see some people looking
at me will do so I'll assume that their
hand was raised so so effect what I have
down here is a chart that shows the
number of like 90 percent is like one
nine two nines it's 99 all the way up to
about five nines and in this chart you
see the number of seconds per day that
you can be down
industry average for I see I'm tethered
to this thing we're gonna okay so
industry average that for a cloud
service is like right here this is like
three not three and a half nines if you
go look at AWS or or Google cloud they
will they will only support 99.95 and if
they don't get that they'll give you 10%
of your money back so if you spent you
know if you lost your account because
you have a legal agreement that that
takes you beyond this guy and you have a
fairly stringent constraint on your
because enterprise wants constraints you
can't go past this line feasibly unless
you actually start managing a lot of the
system in different ways but usually
what happens though if you read the fine
print they actually don't have to give
you three point five nine so they only
really usually promise about man this
thing is okay
okay use a mouse no but they usually
give you around two and a half nines or
the rebate gets a little bit steeper at
one and a half nine or something and so
it really is the case that the cloud
services aren't really helping you very
much if you have to deliver out here in
the three and a half 9s range which I
think some industries like that's just
like a requirement right if you're doing
credit card fraud detection we are on
the we're in the the line of the
e-commerce
so if anonymous user comes to a website
and they need to get fitted before they
get to us we end up in that category
those three half nines but one thing I
will say is that well like for example
like Visa and Capital One will care a
lot about always having much much higher
rate because they constantly have
traffic most commercial websites aren't
that way right there's long down times
there's time there's there's spiked
times and for everyone who's like really
familiar with server theory you know
you're gonna get a Q going and your your
response times going to go down quite a
bit at in certain peak times
so really what you really need is not
just the up time but like kind of a
maintenance and other things kind of fit
into it so like the contract can get
very hairy or you can just say oh we
just do something and just don't kill us
the the API uptime so the one thing I've
missed at the top is like on all of
these things you have to have something
that's going to monitor it and I think
that monitoring your data and how it
works and your algorithm is very
important throughout the process of
actually going to deploy and selling
your your things and so in this case we
we just use a polling service but
there's lots of different ways to do
this so the second bit of that API is
the response time so here is kind of
like for something I guess it's
behavioral psychology and other things
it's kind of ingrained and stone a
certain known a certain kind of
requirement for response times for
example page loads tend to need to be in
within 800 milliseconds so that's the
number I've been given like if your page
doesn't load within 800 milliseconds
people click off because we're
Millennials and we we don't wait for
people yeah but but then you have the
second one which is a page update like I
did something and it has to update and
200 milliseconds is the number given
we're talking like two eye blinks so if
you blink you blink your eyes twice it's
done right and then a GUI response is
somewhere just to give you a kind of a
reference is 37 like 30 milliseconds so
between these times you have certain
things you can do and if you're working
on a data data set that's going to take
more than 50 milliseconds you can't be
in this page because well it might be
200 milliseconds here you got to take
you got to take off 80 milliseconds for
the query to get to you because that's
that's 200 milliseconds on the device
that calls to you okay and so if you if
you have a model that can hit 50
milliseconds you can be here if you have
a model that's gonna take a lot longer
but you can like maybe direct to another
page and like have something you can be
you can be 800 milliseconds so you can
be get a lot more time if you're the
page load level and if you can't get in
that ballpark then you have to do some
back system or something something else
so I love like all the methods that
people talk about but a lot of them
can't hit this right and so if if you if
your model can't hit that then you have
to think about another delivery it can't
be a RESTful API and and that's that's
just the realities we often work in so I
think that that's one thing that's often
missed about like how fast can I
actually predict sometimes so yeah and
that's basically all I'd I think there
are a lot of tricks you can hide things
for for example for us will sometimes
play a trick where we can maybe get
people to create a profile and things
like that and link up to like actually a
merge database or something so but to
monitor that so I didn't put this on
here but you got a monitor this guy as
well and the monitor it you basically
just have to have some sort of real time
database that's going to monitor every
query because or you can miss some it
doesn't really matter but you have to
have something that's actually
monitoring your queries inside and
outside your system because otherwise
you're not going to be able to come back
to that legal agreement say hey no I
actually did what you said that sort of
thing so
so this one's just kind of a short kind
of like eating a support response so you
have to hire teamm to like actually tell
what happened and so this is comes where
it's very important to have logs so you
can understand what happened so you can
replay what happened I think that that
need to replay your your your model and
understand like from like a functional
state and that can I get back what
happened if you do this right and you
monitor errors and you have a really
nice print log you can get a head start
on any like support calls because if if
someone's website goes down and you get
it you get it in five minutes and they
call you fifteen minutes later you just
had ten minutes to work right but that's
the hope anyways so when you're
designing out a system like how do i
reproduce what happened there is very
important
okay so that's so those those are kind
of the constraints now where are you
gonna host it so how many people have so
coming to have actually used AWS before
awesome okay so that how many people
used to Roku before okay awesome how
many people run their own server awesome
okay so we actually have so I'm gonna go
through these pretty quickly about like
what are the the options here and I'm
gonna get down to like why I chose to
use an ie the infrastructure service
kind of thing so hosting options like is
run your own host like Etsy runs their
own hardware there's a ton of sunk costs
and you have to pay for your system
administrators but you gonna manage the
SLA and your and you're actually much
more you have a lot more ability to
affect that and so that's definitely a
thing that's fading like not a lot of
people run their own hardware for web
scale type things but there are some
people who are like if I optimize the
heck out of it I can just run like you
literally you can run like a quarter of
the servers that you need to run in the
cloud because the virtualization
actually does cost quite a bit
the another kind of the other options
like a Rackspace type deal where or
where they have managed hardware so you
pay Rackspace to manage your hardware
somewhere so you lose some of that sunk
cost but your PIN and you're paying a
portion of some system ministries time
so that's nice that you have to pay for
a full person but you're negotiating an
SLA so now you have a third party that
you're in there with SLA so that that
problem I had before where my cloud
providers not gonna give me an SLA I
need well you can negotiate an SLA here
and get it but it's gonna cost you so
the next one I kind of put down is like
you can use a platform as a service like
Heroku or elastic beanstalk or there's a
number of these kind of Google App
Engine and these are like really easy to
use
the idea is you like you get you just
upload a git and some code and it'll run
it will put on systems and things like
that
snow sunk costs no need for a system
administrator but as you start to scale
that chart as you start to have more
more calls in that chart of costs
supposed to go down it doesn't really
work that way here because like their
bottle is the more calls you get they're
going to get cost because they're a SAS
platform as well and so definitely the
case of people will get locked into
these systems and be paying a lot more
money than they then they work they
should be and also it's definitely the
case that I didn't put this in here to
to embarrass them but Heroku actually
literally says like we will try to be a
hundred percent up but we make no
promises which is like basically not I
mean it's just I can't do that wait but
for a lot of people that's fine is like
if if your if your API can go down for
an hour that's fine but some people
can't so if you in it and if you can use
a platform as a service versus another
another system I would actually use it
but it's definitely that the expense and
the SLA is became just not something we
could do then the final one is
infrastructure as a service which is a
little bit of a not really that much
different from platform as a service
except that you can log into your
servers it's kind of how I kind of
differentiate it
login to my servers and kind of set up
my own network or do I just give someone
some system to run my code the
infrastructure service there's a lot
less issue of maybe the SLA because you
can put it over multiple clouds you can
mitigate some of those issues and but it
is the case that you're gonna roll your
own deployment so you can mitigate the
SLA roll your own deployment and they're
usually the price point is not like per
query that's definitely this like uptime
and things like that so you can really
manage if you're getting more calls it
meets the business needs that we have
okay so where we picked so I pick the
infrastructure as a service just because
I need to make the business case for it
what other people do varies all over the
place so now I want to switch a little
bit and talk about the architecture so
how are we actually gonna serve the
model so the first kind of architecture
everybody kind of like gloms to in data
science world is this notion of a the
lambda architecture and this definitely
has a plate I think um there's a talk
yesterday about like hosting the parts
of the lambda of architecture and things
like this and so this is the notion of
like you have data coming in you want to
do models or or some processes and get
something that you're serving out of it
and you have like three layers right you
have a Bachelor serving layer and a
speed layer the speed layer is for like
very like incremental views or very
quick analytics bachelors for overnight
type things and you merge it all
together and you can serve pieces out of
it so in this kind of notion like will
get data coming in from our clients
about their clients and so on and so
this becomes like just a database that
we can see but it's definitely a case
for us we also have to have this bottom
layer which this is actually from a
parts description they they use storm
but that bottom layer it's also
producing some of the predictions and
the models so lambda architecture is
great for getting your data into a
system you can pull
from I think Huddle's talks the other
yesterday that was really good about
talking about how you build this sort of
thing then you prove do you have to
present it as a service and so here's
the kind of like micro-services
architectures like an old older was
called microkernels architecture so you
have some service that will call into
these databases but also might actually
predict your model or depending on what
whatever you do and also going to hit
all those monitoring requests and
everything we do there as well
and so you have some interface layers so
the API gateway is a typical type of
thing you do and then you can everybody
can hit your data and get into the
pieces so this is kind of I thought
there's a nice light on what the
bite-mark creatures in the software
architectures books but this is kind of
what you're doing is you're gonna need a
spawn off a lot of these guys so you can
respond to that request and you can keep
on spawning them all so your as your
cost goes up or as your need for more
data calls go up you can respond to that
elastically so our first attempt at
doing something was a very kind of
monolithic approach where we have a
gateway and we have someone who's
actually going to call the model so this
green box down here was like where I was
a year ago and I had the model working
we built this nice system where I have
up in red I have all these different
monitoring systems I have a load
balancer to carry to these systems but
the end of the day like these are pretty
monolithic and so I have like a web
server in there because to another web
server cuz god bless flask and an api
gateway we try to do it all in python
everywhere it could we used RDS to store
like all our merged data because we only
have like a couple hundred million rows
we're not like that big yet and then we
used a cache for all our hot data and
that was pretty pretty simple way of
handling everything but as you start
making more deals you have to start
monitoring things you have to start
reporting more you have to give like
scale up and so this system worked great
for our first kind of like tent so we
probably got to about a thousand a day
she was fine but then we started to
notice that there's some some things
that weren't working quite right because
kept on scaling it
so I flipped it over to a more of a
services viewpoint and so here what I
have is all the services we run today
and their dependencies like who pulls
like if it's if there's an arrow it
points to another service this point
like pulling from it so we go back so up
there is our API the actual thing that
we're supposed to be making money off of
but if 17 other services is actually run
and and it's serviced this thing so
people can actually use it right I break
it down like we have our client facing
services such as a dashboard and a demo
area and email things then we have
asynchronous tasks and our data layers
and and so and then our monitoring layer
is actually quite large because that's
what you know controls your your legal
agreement that you know you made it
right so once you're at this place
manage your own servers everything like
managing every single server you're
doing becomes a real challenge
especially when there's only four of you
so where there's only four there's only
four of us at the time we built this to
actually manage code code and so we we
made a decision to go to kate kubernetes
or k-8 and that like it's like change
kind of our whole kind of way of doing
things and made it much easier now you
think we think about services and each
one of these boxes can be tested and
monitored and used independently so it's
no longer just one big thing that has
you hope all the tests are working you
hope the coverage was right and
everything else you can actually cover
all those pieces so that's what got us
to we need all these different kind of
services we need to interact with the
system and our clients and we needed a
tool to kind of use it so we we fell up
down upon kubernetes and and dr. and
these things so that's where I am today
I'd like to go through just like some of
the tools that we use to deploy all
these pieces
so hopefully you understand why we got
here and it's not it's not always that
the road you you think it's going to be
on
so just so we based I have like three
kind of solutions we need to support so
DevOps is a term that like doesn't
really have a definition but it's got
the word dev in it so there's something
about coding right and it's op so
there's some operations so I usually
start off like how do I make my
developers lives the easiest and the
first thing I do is I make sure they can
code on the laptop I might be running on
a distributed system and I mean I've
used this this this like I've actually
been I was an HPC before I went to
industry and like yeah I had codes it'll
scale to a hundred thousand processes
and it would run on my laptop before I
put it on the server right so number one
like get it to work on your laptop like
you subsample your day to do something
because like the faster you can go on
your laptop and if people say oh don't
use a laptop use a cluster you just like
say no no this is a portly man and in DC
pi day that told me that I can get
things to run on my laptop and so I'll
talk a little bit anaconda is amazing
for this like the you can run it on
everybody's laps because this is the
nightmare say everyone has a different
laptop everyone has a different
environment I can't do that and docker
is really a hard time like actually
getting my developers to work inside a
docker image so anaconda is really great
about that then you have to ship your
code of the system and your Ops guys cuz
they're the other half of that DevOps
they're gonna hate you if you just give
them an anaconda
I mean there'll be a lot happier than if
you just give them a run dot SH that
worked on your computer but docker like
is kind of become the standard of that
and they'll take a little bit more about
that and then like at the end of it like
just you have to change your viewpoint
once you get to big enough is like your
service there's a lot of other services
you can manage and people will start
managing your services and whether you
did whether your company's doing running
monoliths or not now because they're
gonna scale at all like services end up
coming a part of it they say also it's
always strange to me like here's like Oh
micro service is the way everything
like yeah but we've known the services
of the right way for a long long time we
just think we called them soap or so or
other things right we didn't call micro
services but so kubernetes is that kind
of piece that really brings that home so
what do I love about anaconda anaconda
gives me one file that I can install
everything that might that we need and
so I guess just to break down because
like there's a lot of like nice features
here like I have a name of an
environment I can tell like channels
that so that I know where what repo
stick pull code from so I can deliver
binary code to a place that's always the
same I can list out dependencies for the
condo world to install which it knows
how to install in KL and and numpy and
things like that in my system correctly
well then I get all the pip libraries as
well I'm using this kind of fun pip
notation so if you have like Pip and
Cole you can say give me pip pip and
sellable package as well and so that
right there made it so that instantly
all my data science or all my team could
could run the code on the laptop so if
somebody says they can't run their code
on my laptop like we sit down we talk
about how you run Kannada and everything
else so everyone gets on that page you
can run on your laptop so and it's still
all one yeah Mille so the next llamo
file I used as a doctor doctor says
anybody not know what docker is can read
raise your hand all right cool
so docker is I should have put more on
here but so doctor this is their slide
actually because I shamelessly stole
because I was asked to talk Nick last
week but this is a I think this sums it
up really well it's it's would you think
of it like a shipping container for your
code and so the technology underneath is
doesn't matter as much to me but on it
but you have a virtual uh you know
virtualized or isolate your system and
it uses a single file that will tell you
how to install and it does so in a
reproducible way and so yet again a
single yamo file that will take your
repo and can turn it into something
that's runnable
on any system that can run a this this
Linux hypervisor so there's a lot of
like really kind of cool ecosystem
around it but the notion is is you can
code anything on there and host it
anywhere through the shipping container
and just like when you ship paper you
don't create a special box you put a lot
of paper in a shipping container and
then the shipping container goes across
the world right the same thing with code
the the things I would say is that it's
it takes a little learning curve as far
as it's one yamo file but you have to
learn how to like build on it and it's
in its own little environment and but
there's and there's a lot of ecosystem
because then you're using another image
so you have like the image of the docker
image of all your files and everything
that's there and it has to be stored
someplace and that has to be managed and
pretty soon just like shipping
containers you get boats and lots of
them as that's what you need
kubernetes for so kubernetes is like
that the helmsman or the root of a well
okay the governor in cybernetics the
Greek but the person who's going to take
all these shipping containers and get
them to port okay and so it's really
just like orchestration it builds on
docker containers and so I like those 17
services but of those services the API
is gonna have like five or six nodes and
maybe the the data layers gonna have
five or six nodes and things like that
and so just to so it'll actually build
on that it'll take all those containers
and actually throw them on your your
cluster and make it so that they're
redundant and so on it came out of
Google there's a lot of like there's a
lot of blogs about it kubernetes and
like how it's like their third system
and it's it's an opinionated
architecture and so I think that's
probably the biggest knock people have
so kubernetes isn't the only container
management system out there docker has
its own docker swarm it's a it's a lot
newer than kubernetes and then there's
like every cloud has their own like so
well so GCP has the kubernetes but
amazon has their own kind of container
manager
do I forget ECR maybe and then there's
an azure one as well so there's a lot of
these systems but this one is open and
you don't have to like manage a lot of
different pieces on it and so do you
come in a notion of what what it's doing
under the hood this is its architecture
so what it has is as a master that's
going to have some controllers and an
API and it's going to schedule these
containers on a bunch of workers so
cubelets then so it can schedule jobs
through containers throughout the code
and that each one of these things that
it knows things that have to go together
so you can there's a way you can specify
yet again with not one um will file but
more like four but you know we're only
up to six yeah mo file so that most
people can handle 60ml files but under
the hood you have a data store that's
going to like tell everybody what like
where they're running what they're
running you have services that will map
to the different parts of these and so
you can touch kind of touch it with the
web browser and see how things are
working or you can use cube control
which will just send your images over
and things like that and so it's a
full-on distributed system that's
running your services within these cubes
and so the I think if you walk away in
front of talk it's like you're gonna
need something to manage all these
pieces and kubernetes is like a really
good choice it has everything kind of
built in swarm is the kind of the
biggest competitor right now docker
swarm and the the biggest advantage dr.
swarm has the same API is docker the
biggest challenge right is that you
don't get all these pieces you only kind
of get like the the farm right and so it
doesn't have nearly as many like
rescheduling things and like keeping
things coherent as you have to manage
the network yourself and things like
that so dr. swarm will be there in a
year or two and so then you'll just have
to just have to get in a room and fight
but today kubernetes has like all the
kind of different pieces there and so
what how you use it is that you have a
service
which is just a collection of pods pods
are just images with environments and
like for example I've got to be
connected to this this database or I
have to be connected to this service or
this data file and there's replicators
things like this service always has to
be running this service runs once the
service runs on ten ten nodes it's like
also it becomes trivial to deploy a new
model in kubernetes because one of the
reasons we also in the isolation is that
we want our functions to be completely
isolated in a docker image you can't
have once you start moving around the
docker image you don't have your your
hard drive anymore you don't have your
states your kind of guarantee that's
going to be reproducible to call that
thing but what you get what you end up
doing is with these replicators you can
say alright at model one now I've
modeled one point one I can launch a new
service and then replicators once it
gets up I can automatically have it move
traffic from service one to service one
point one and and see it actually take
over so you can continuously deploy your
models very easily and like that's the
feature that like made it where I was
like alright we've got to use this guy
so the canary deployment the other kind
of really cool feature there is just
keeping your if you if your note kind of
goes down or if it starts you can set up
services so it starts to have errors you
can have the old service kind of kick
back up and so there's this Auto
throttling kind of thing and so here's
their huge list of features so the
scheduling which is kind of a what
everyone does but this lifecycle
management and health scaling you can
make this the containers much bigger
really quickly before we did this it was
taking us I think four hours to get like
AWS to launch all our stuff because you
had to check everything now it takes us
10 minutes
so now to get the docker built it still
takes an hour but if I have a docker
image I can in ten minutes I can have a
new model running yeah and so so all
these other kind of like really great
features of it so
kubernetes is awesome and now we're back
to ah our model is deployed it's time to
dance
thank you so much any questions
okay do you have the monitoring stuff
running in the same code coverage Oscar
to be up to four questions like I got
some water managed to make sure you're
actually yeah so how do I know that I'm
monitoring correctly so in here I have
external services right so actually I
still use like already our DB RDS and
some other external data because I want
them to manage it but I have I have like
a polar right that's external and I have
a log aggregator and an error notifier
although it's not up here but I also
have a run scope which oh like any
exception is thrown it those UDP packet
outside my cluster but then if Griffin
occurs then we have actually have a
monitor as Agri fauna charts the show
like API so if that goes out well we'll
know very quickly as well so but no
that's one of the reasons like you have
to monitor like there's different levels
of monitoring there and so you just have
to have it all kind of if you don't have
it it's you don't know what's going to
it really is kinda you learned very
quickly that if it's not monitored it
didn't happen like it's like if it's not
cross validated it's wrong it's a just
not monitored it didn't happen if it's
not tested it's not coded I mean these
things yeah
yeah so I'm using both one of the nice
things about being a start-up is that
there's a war going on right now between
these providers and so they've both
given me a lot of credits on and so the
nice thing about so Google container
engine is like they manage kubernetes
for you you don't have to set it up at
all you just say I want this many knows
that look like this and I just use cube
control and like throw everything up
there the nice thing about AWS is that
they their databases are a lot nicer so
the now I'm told that that's that's
changing that they're getting better
like their databases are becoming better
at Google but like we moved over there
and instantly we weren't because we
still have some database already some
sequel databases again some of the
logging systems we just saw that go way
down and so we like some of the other
managed services that AWS has that
Google hasn't caught quad up caught up
with so I mean it's like in that it's
just a race I mean like which do they
need I mean like Google took down their
their Hadoop cluster their Hadoop
clusters a while back and like so you
don't really they try to push everyone a
dataflow and get away from MapReduce and
so they it's kind of like a services
type thing like what service do you have
and but as far as running kubernetes if
you go to the kubernetes repo there's
this cops which is this Kop a switch
kubernetes ops and it can it can have
scripts that can just like launch
anything like on the the AWS nodes but
the other the only kind of nasty part is
that you have to you have to setup more
services in AWS like network peering a
few other things but that's kind of one
thing you wants and there's nice guides
but with gke you press a button or
Google container and you press a button
and it comes up so
yep that's right
are you practical question
are using the savings since tight for
all of your notes or you realized to
optimal thanks yeah I'm using the same
because once again I'm not paying you
you can actually describe like that's
what part of the animal file is
describing what needs the services so
you can say this service needs to gigs
around this one needs one this needs
like so much compute this one needs the
other and so then kubernetes will look
at your cluster and schedule it and
it'll monitor like oh hey this thing is
like taking nine person oh the CPU I'll
move it over and so that's some of the
nice kind of features of kubernetes has
so it has a lot of features to help
manage that but I've not I'm not dived
into that just yet because I'm still in
that like upper cost port so I can I
don't have to drive the cost down all
the way to it yet so I've tried lots of
things right so like there's vagrant
there's there's just open box v I mean
actually the one thing that actually
developers like VMware speaking at
VMware working then most people are like
oh this is actually works well but I fee
and where it cost a lot for a small
start-up and so I don't taste that but
uh but yeah so the other side is you
have to manage that that that imp those
images as well and so now you have
another state to manage versus one ya
know file so yeah so I still like Conda
there
no that's part of the test script it'll
so I have docker on my laptop and it'll
install and run on my laptop right it's
probably like so they test inside it and
that's the other thing is like because
you're gonna need tests throughout all
the system and like your service needs
when you want to do monitoring you're
like you you have that five a.m. phone
call you just want to say you know API
self test
well that's the same self test that's on
your laptop so people are used to it and
like then anybody can help with the
system so cool well I think we're over
so there's a break and thank you very
much for your attention